hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar NMR into analyzing biomarkers
for personalized medicine where do
bio-based come in presented by Professor
Mathias now nd and moderated by dr. Mann
central
I am Alexis Clouse of labyrinth and I'll
do producing today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by labyrinth and sponsored by burger
burger enables scientists to make
breakthrough discovery and develop new
applications that improve the quality of
human life regrowth high-performance
scientific instruments and high value
and a little a diagnostic solution
enable scientists to explore life and
materials on molecular cellular and
microscopic level for more information
please visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
as you want at any time you want during
the presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click on the phone button
your questions will be addressed by the
speakers we have the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking your answers
question box located on the far left ear
screen lastly at the end of the
presentation you will receive a poll
survey which we kindly ask you to
complete your answers and suggestions
will help improve our webinar programs
and are greatly appreciated it is now
time to our presentation moderated by
dr. mantas bra
hello so Thank You Alexis for the nice
introduction and thank you everyone for
joining us today our webinar today is
titled Anna mine standardizing
biomarkers for personalized medicine via
to bio banks come in it is presented by
Professor Matias Milk MD who has an out
actually completed his medical studies
at the University Hospital in Freiburg
in Germany in 1997 he became specialist
for laboratory medicine after obtaining
his doctorate in 1992 he received his
habilitation in the year 2000 and since
2002 for his analyst director of the
Institute of clinical chemistry and
Laboratory Medicine at the University
Medicine Inc life's worth what is an elk
you can now begin your presentation yes
mine crevasse thank you very much for
this kinda adaption and hello to
everybody in this audience I will die
after the presentation clinical
metabolic risk by one atrium our
spectroscopy according to Transparency
statement I receive an array of from
during an mi manned Becton Dickinson
cause I things and there are a lot of
research support and funding from
several companies you can read from the
slide in my talk I will cover the topics
metabolomics tree and analytic effects
the epidemiological epidemiology and by
obeying things I will talk about type 2
diabetes mellitus and mark up glucose
metabolism I will talk about this
biological age lipoprotein subfractions
and fatty liver disease starting with
the topic metabolomics we learned over
the last decade to get information about
our genome about our transcriptome the
proteome and the metabolome
and we know that these earth
technologies onyx are influenced in part
by aged I attract lifestyle and for
we are especially interested in the
metabolome because the metabolome cover
of a lot of these different aspects and
the metabolome is closely linked to our
diseases we have the opportunity to look
at the metabolome and to get information
about subclinical
situations and this will help us to
improve the medicine in future
the metabolomics as you find is the
entirety of more molecules typically
less than 1/2 the doors in a biological
sounds like blood or urine but also
increases or things that we apply the
metabolomics or biomarker discovery for
pathway discovery from pharmaco
metabolomics or translation of
biomarkers inference new one screening
but this is not the topic of this talk
today
in general we apply two different
techniques to look into our metabolome
on the one hand side the mass
spectrometry and on the other side the
nuclear magnetic resonance spectroscopy
of course these methods have advantages
and disadvantages the mass spectrometry
has a very high sensitivity and we need
only a very small sample volume if on
the other side the attractive techniques
with relatively high cough and an
extensive sample preparation on the
other side the NMR is highly
reproducible a very important expect I
will show you later
we need only minimal standard operation
and one of the favorite is a
non-destructive technique the relativity
is lower in comparison to the MS and in
general we need higher sample volume in
future the combination of both methods
it's very important to and theory with
your picture of the metabolic profiler
where we have the combination of MS and
NMR using the same sample using an
automatic pipetting robot and here you
can see that the NMR and MF spectroscopy
are really combined in one analytical
step
when we look is the NMR spectroscopy
juicy a spectrum like here from a urine
sample and we have a lot of substances
we can really define and measure and
quantify and the quantification is
possible of through the addition of only
one standard EFP and according to the
TFP peak we can quantify our expenses
within the spectra in general we have
two different ways to analyze these data
of the NMR spectroscopy we have the
targeted way and the untargeted ways as
i already mentioned the targeted way we
have the absolute concentration dollars
of the spectra and we can quantify
metabolites so for further specific
analysis this is more or less
established rate who uses an alive as in
classical clinical chemistry and on the
other side the untargeted approach in
this approach we divide the sector into
smaller regions which are called buckets
with a fixed width and then we look at
these packets and look if there are any
associations between the bucket and the
height of the bucket in view of some
associations through clinical aspect
when we are applying biological samples
we learn from our cynically chemistry
and levels are met and knowledge that
pre analytic plays a very important role
and they say observe in the many
situations
changes of our analytes according to not
sufficient or not other cloud sample
separations and therefore we look
carefully at these extracts of the pre
analytical approach and here do you see
in this slide our study design we
collected urine and the three involve
start at minus eighty-degree says they
were started 10 degrees cells and a room
temperature for different time periods
and then we looked at the animal spectra
of these different processed in Santa's
and as you can see on the slide we have
overall tens
different subjects and here you see the
colored lights of these points which
they are measured out their difference
we analytical States and we can state
that the pre analytic aspects are less
strong than inter-individual differences
so we can state that the urine from one
person to another person as a quite
different matter below and the changes
which we observe qmg ageing of these
samples is relatively low the freezing
of Sanders as minus 80 degrees seems to
be sufficient and the majority of
metabolites or stable up to 24 hours at
10 degree Celsius we observe changes in
urine if there is an infection of the
bladder and then there are substances
with training metabolome with an arrow
coming back to the analytical phase I
show you on this slide the situation
that we measured in our clinical
chemistry laboratory
Tampa's with requests for glucose
determination and we determined the
glucose some in diplucate just minutes
under came in on the x-axis is the first
value and on the y-axis is the second
value and the sample measurement with
the time between these measurements are
draft minutes so we can say that we
immediate merited appliquéd and here you
see this some the results are not
identical but they are really close to
each other for this analytical way
itself is quite precise and accurate
when you look at this sample this slide
here wery measured some turbot restored
in our bio banks for a period of 5 years
and it's always there cause filtration
as in the first example and here you see
that the deviation is a little bit
higher comes here to the first slide but
taking into account that the time period
is now five years between these two
measurements deceleration is quite good
when we look at this slide we measured
the glucose concentration in samples
after a storage period of fifteen years
and of course the scatter is a little
bit higher but in general we can say
that the glucose determination after
fifteen years give make more or less the
same result as in the sample which we
measured right on the wave on the
program that was collected
so in general we are able to store our
sounds in an adequate way especially
when we look at the analyte of glucose
and this samples the vitamin b12
concentration was determined in the
original contact rate on the x-axis and
after five years the y-axis and here do
you see that you knew the younger
concentrations are much lower and of
course you can stay this is an effect of
our analytic pre-analytical phase of the
bio banking's
but in this situation the case is a
change of the laboratory assay and this
is one of the problems in paternity
chemistry today that changing of SAS or
as a platforms may have real impact on
the analytics and when we are look in
epidemiological ways where we measure
samples in the year 2000 and we measure
new earth on basis you were in the year
two thousand and ten or fifteen and we
have real problems if we have trained
with India of the analytics because in
such situations we cannot state that the
beta mimic concentrate for instance is
increasing or decreasing and therefore
the accuracy of measurements is quite
important and this is one of the real
benefit of the NMR spectroscopy because
the data are really comparable
independent if there are time period
between these two determinations is 15
years or more we started in graphite
with our video melodica studies in 1997
the rice right is located in the
northeast part of Germany and you can
see Berlin and Hamburg and at the Baltic
Sea is located rice variety in 1997 we
started with a study comparable to the
Framingham Heart Study we collected the
campus of four tower which we had an
intense province and located in this
area with an age of twenty-two seventy
nine years and ten years later we
started with another study 50 trent and
these study is very important for our
knowledge which we can detect with the
NMR spectroscopy overall the collected
in the mean time about 1 million aliquot
for our bio banks and the bio banking
topic is quite important and then we
look at the literature we know that in
many aspects the bio bank and procedures
are not as good as there would be you
really need a very high quality process
of our sample preparation the collection
of the samples at the start of our
farmers and in many situations it is
written that there is an insufficient
provision of biomaterial firm ation for
publication dated in nature in 2011 so
it's one of our main expect to be very
careful with our samples and to make the
professor's sure and of course we're
interested in quality control effects so
that we can state that our families are
ok which we use for arm effort in
addition to the ship studying in germany
we started a few years ago a huge
epidemiological study the so called
german national cohort in this cohort we
are collecting two hundred thousand
problems all over germany you can see
the fat offenders in the denmark
and we collect these samples in 18
study centers in the major diseases we
are looking for is cardiovascular
disease diabetes mellitus cancer and so
on on the next slide you see how many
cases we affect during this period
follow-up periods of this study so we
can look at any cancer and after five
years five thousand seven years thirty
thousand fifteen years twenty one
thousand twenty years twenty nine
thousand cases with any kind of cancer
there's quite a lot but when we
differentiate our counters into brief
prostate colon lung and so on the
affected number here are quite low and
therefore it's very important to have a
so huge cohort that we are able to look
at these cases with small numbers of
cancer more in detail and that we will
be able to detect for instance
biomarkers which will be helpful if you
try to detect these persons as early as
possible the bio banking or the national
cohort is mainly located in the head not
central near Munich and we are store the
samples in a central way and the liquid
phase of nitro dreams minus 180 degrees
Celsius and here you see a sketch of the
bio repository where we have 18 tanks
it's or this tank is a diameter of 0.5
meter and these things are fully
automated so that you can they handle
the samples even at these low
temperatures we have to be careful when
we look at our zombies and when you
compare our founders from different
studies so that we do not have apples on
the one side and here on the others and
therefore we are glad that we have now a
tools available from Brooklyn where we
can check our own biomes Bank samples at
the very beginning when we stall the
Sounders at the one hand side and on the
other side
when we look at these founders of a
third period of ten years for instance
and then we have a lot of flex where we
have two results available and one
example on the right hand side with the
NMR spectroscopy is quite easy to detect
if we are using ETA plasma or serum or
Hyperion plasma for instance and in
general clinical chemistry is quite hard
to define at the end of the way we have
to mirror for instance potassium and we
can conclude it might be due to a plasma
but this is a valuable information and
when the collection of samples we
observe some errors then one of these
errors is the exchange of serum or ETA
plasma coming to the clinical aspects of
the NMR spectroscopy I will switch to
the topic of diabetes mellitus diabetes
mellitus is of course a very prominent
disease and the incidence rate of
diabetes mellitus is quite different all
over the world but the main aspect I
have to take into account is that
roughly 50% of the diabetics currently
do not know that they are diabetes so
despite our solubility
to measure glucose meta hba1c and so on
we have really many many people which
are not aware of this disease in the
personalised aspect and therefore I
think we need a different instrument we
need much better instrument to look into
the future detect these people much more
early and I will show you the result of
to study the ship study from graphite he
receive allocated berlin and hamburg and
the inter 99 study which is performed
with our could eat in Denmark in
Copenhagen coming to the study of v
studying rye flight there we looked at
2007
participants and we had a 5-year
follow-up period in this five-year fall
appears we observed 137 new diabetic
cases we looked at the animal
spectroscopy of the urine and performed
some analysis here do you see the
results of this study on the right hand
side they are the data of the women on
the left-hand side the blue shears are
from man and on the x-axis and the
y-axis they are listed the analytes
which we determined and then we
calculated ratios between the excess
analyte from the h axis of the analyzed
on the y-axis and we look into more
detail into the data we have some
analyzed like alanine light streams turn
in and so on these are clearly
associated with diabetes mellitus and
this is the confirmation of previous
findings with the established way on the
other hand we are able to find new
analytes which have associations with
type 2 diabetes mellitus and the
incidence of these cases in these
equations of TMAO and trigger a lean
quite beneficial in women and here you
see the ROC curve of our analysis the
yellow lines in this case we use the
ring glucose in the listed analytes
trigonal enantiomer Oh in addition and
then the iscap and is much better and as
a significant difference between these
two rock row so the addition of
additional IDEs increase the possibility
to detect persons with incidentally
abilities more in advance so when we
look in changes in the glycome k---mart
of up to now mostly case control design
focus on the classification of incident
diabetic cases regular changes the
chemical control could be addressed
using changes and continuous markers
like fasting plasma glucose glycated
hemoglobin or insulin resistance
and to predict those strangers we are
applying durian metabolite measurements
we want to know into the Lord to look
into the future
applying these you mean metabolites
which is quite promising and within the
inter ninety nine study we have two
subgroups on the one hand side the whole
population is nearly 4-thousand probe
and on the fact the second the third
group with no signs of diabetes
meditative with a number of 1,350 around
and when we look at the dater of the
arena battle ohm measured at the
baseline and five years later which are
correlated with each other and we see
that there are a lot of analytes
which have a quite good saw relation
between the concentration at the
baseline urine and in the ruined after
five years follow-up and the Spearman
correlation greater than 0.4 is a hint
of a metabolic fingerprint of these
probe and we see that there is a
constant concentration in the urine
concentrations and therefore we can
apply these concentrations these
analyzed for medical services until you
see the way how we looked at these data
we observed the percent change in
glucose young follow up a 10% increase
in baseline metabolites so on the y-axis
you see a lot of metabolites and these
metabolites changed by 10% during this
time period of five years we see that
the glucose concentration increases by
0.1 0.2 percent flipped found not very
very much but it's obvious for uncreate
amines in collaboration with the glucose
and we have the same finding when we
look at the hba1c or on the Roma index
according to the insulin resistance
so we see changes in our analyte and we
can predict the changes in glucose
concentration and therefore we are able
to look into the ruing metabolome and we
are able to define people who ever were
at an increased risk to develop diabetes
mellitus when we look at these analyzed
more in detail material mean and
immaterial mean these are markers of
shift in the gut microbiome one of the
new omec fears and this makes absolute
sense because diabetes mellitus is
clothing related to the traditional
habit of when we look at the changes in
the glutamic markers here you see the
spectra and the different substances in
the targeted approach and in the fields
below this we have the bucket the
untargeted approach on the cough or
scroll we feel there are areas with a
blue sky where we do not find a real
analyte but the other targeted throws
gives up the information which is
helpful to divide these stations into at
risk or not at rest
one of the other ethics we use the urine
metabolome is a biological age and we
use the urine metabolome of the zip 0
cohort as well and the quantification of
59 analyzed and we analyze on our
available flying the Brooker
quantification in the reen algorithms
and we looked at these data and we
calculated by Audrey k-8 of course we
have the chronological age we have
presented in our passport and then we
looked at the metabolome and differences
in the metabolome when we look at the
skin of a Hume and it's clear when we
have a baby it has other skin type then
in a diet or in really old person and of
course the metabolome has changes with
age as well and we are we try to look
more into detail and on the right hand
side you can see that there are
situations is which makes you younger
like physical activity and cases which
make you order like smoking or diabetes
mellitus and we could clearly show that
persons with the manifest diabetes
mellitus as a higher biological age and
therefore a higher risk to develop
diseases and to die when we are looking
at the metabolome at all here we see the
age ranges from a 20 years old person to
a 40 to a six to eighty per year old
persons
applying these data from the ship study
and we see of course they are little bit
stranger in future we want to combine
many data from different epidemiological
studies to look at the changes during
life starting in the area of the new
bond and of course than the era and
become older and then at the end of this
a trajectory these are data from the 20
to 80 years old men currently we are
establishing eight specific reference in
device for the metabolome and the aim is
to develop analytical tools for
determination and analysis of these data
and of course you want to detect people
where illnesses are underway to develop
but of course you want to look at the
metabolome
to receive these persons quite early so
that they are beneficial in view of
additional medical therapeutic
approaches so I want to conclude the
type 2 diabetes topic subclinical
changes in glycemic control the unary
fingerprint those relate to shift in the
gut microbiome nutritional behavior and
one Cobo metabolism and the biological
age score is able to summarize complex
metal
interact in addition to our
epidemiologist wrote we established in
Greece lies so-called nganimate shows
like the graphite approach to
individualized medicine the objective is
to use state-of-the-art diagnostic the
novel therapeutics intervention they
take into account specific requirements
and characteristics of the individual
patient in order to optimize the
effectiveness of treatments avoid
adverse reactions and reduce health care
costs and we have different clinical
cohorts where we perform very
standardized clinical examination in
part a whole body MRI imaging and of
course we are looking at laboratory
medicine markers and biomarkers include
with the omec approach and one of the
topics for this effect are the more or
less detailed analysis of lipoprotein
fraction attractions here you see the
lipoproteins composition like a tennis
ball in the quad they are the solitaire
Easter and triglyceride and on the
surface there are lipoprotein
phospholipid the uh Ness terrified or
freaks quality rolls and on the right
hand side you will do see that the size
of this lipoproteins is quite different
and we learned over decade that the
Association for instantly ADA
equilateral is the bad cholesterol the
risk of cardiovascular disease
development is much higher in the HDL
our protective
on the other hand when we look more into
detail into the class of the LDL for
instance here's a classic approach with
a huge set of engagement with
authentication process and then we are
able to divide these little proteins in
further operations on the prop
they are the larger particles on down
other small dense LDL particles and on
the right hand side you will see that
these sub fractions are distributed
quite differently
on the left lower hand it's equally
distributed on the right lower hand we
had only large buoyant and small dense
EDL on the right upper side we have
mainly the mid-size areas particles and
we know that the risk according to these
lipoprotein subfractions is quite
different very poor other small deaths
as Al and impart the large areas
particles we are the in-between EDI
particles are not so dangerous for in
the view of the development of
cardiovascular disease so the analysis
and preparation of these lipoprotein
particles is with a classical instrument
quite time intensive and we need about
one week to prepare these samples we
performed more than 200 such
preparations and in addition we measure
these families with a NMR spectra and
applied an algorithm together in
collaboration with Luca bio spins and
now the procedure needs only 30 minutes
and we measure a lot of substances as
you can see and there's overview
triglycerides cholesterol free chorus
phospholipids April 1 a 2 B & B number
of particles and when you apply these
lipoprotein subclass analysis who
receive a lot of results for instance
the triglyceride distribution over the
life of proteins and then in addition
over the lipoprotein subclasses the back
here you see the distribution of the
zombies in general and the concentration
found for the actual sample is a black
bar so you can see that in this case the
triglycerides concentrations in total
VLDL and Eddie are in general a little
bit high they are they are within the
confidence conservation in the HDL
lipoprotein fractions and now I was come
to the fatty liver disease of course the
liver is one of the main organs which is
involved in the metabolism of nearly
everything and on the one hand side we
have see has the liver and we have the
situation that according to our
nutrition and in the lean resistance we
have changes in the liver the n-f-l Rd
the non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
and if the substances continue then we
have other information stimuli and
Doonan resistant and then we've
developed the net and 1i colic their
total hepatitis and this is quite poor
position which is also associated with
other diseases and in such situation in
general we have more cases with type 2
diabetes mellitus
we have more cases with cardiovascular
disease and more cases that chronic
kidney disease so we see that the liver
is a very important organ and when we
look in such situations in data into the
life of Korean sub fractions in our
quadrant to the fatty liver disease and
we perform this in body patients of our
ship friend study where we applied the
whole body MRI and therefore we were
able to quantify the liver fat and then
we observed this is no association
between Freddy liver disease and the
total at equilateral so a negative
realize it doesn't seem to be helpful
when we look more into detail within in
birth association with large dense LDL
and other on the other hand we see a
real positive affirmation with this more
than that is so this is an example from
our point of view which is quite
important that the additional
information we receive and we're looking
at the lipoprotein subfractions detail
is helpful to classify such patients
with such a disease
so I want to summarize my stock NMR is a
robust fast and tidy reproducible
spectroscopic technique to compile a
molecular fingerprints through diseases
the highly informative content of NMR
spectra allows the development of life
trajectories with a single technique the
nm asked one me advances lipoprotein
based diagnostics and risk
stratification and it's translation to
daily clinical practice and the minimal
sample preparation in combination with
highly reproducible measurements a low
for worldwide compilation of comparable
metabolomics data rhyme at the end of
this talk and thank you very much for
your attention thank you both as an alt
for this interest very interesting
presentation Hey what I will do now I
will just know give you some additional
information on the things that were
mentioned here especially of course on D
from the hardware side from the software
side and then also give show you some
tools which will be important in
precision medicine
so let me just switch so I want to talk
about first of all the platform concept
that we are using atom in NMR which is
helping especially for bio banks as I
hope you will see in a short while and
also show you a few examples for what
you can do with personalized metabolic
profiles so when we talk about the IBD
our platform then this is a concept
based on NMR we are IBD R stands for in
vitro diagnostic research and what we
actually want to achieve with this
platform is a completely standardized
and fully automated concept based on
this platform and the solutions that we
are offering into this for clinical and
translational research and of course it
was already mentioned for bio banks a
lot of samples have to be measured and
in several cases of course there will be
a need to have more than one of such
platforms used to actually generate all
the data which are stored you heard
about a very large sample numbers two
hundred thousand there are also bio
banks which have actually more than
million samples stored so this is
definitely a challenge that cannot be
executed by a single instrumentation so
that means there is a need to actually
integrate data from different user
groups and that could be all over the
world and of course if you can select
such data which are generated for
example in bio banks and I will come to
that in a moment or are generated at
different groups like also in the
international phenom center network then
of course we can be much more efficient
in developing also future diagnostic
routines
now you see here a picture of this
platform concept so we start on the
bottom with the IVR platform at 600
megahertz this is standard frequency as
it was used a lot in pharmaceutical
industry and also in clinical
translational research so this is
research use only and on top of that
actually we have then the SOPs we call
that our IV dr methods so these are the
standard procedures that we have for
example for measurement of urine plasma
serum CSF and very soon also further
body fluids or extracts they are
together with that there is a spectral
compound reference base we call this B
by a red code which currently has 800
compounds in there where we have a lot
of 1d and 2d spectra which are used then
to for example identify outliers in
statistical analysis and also of course
play a role in quantification on top of
that we have then in what we call the
tools or enabling tools so this is the
lipoprotein subclass analysis that was
already mentioned there is also a small
molecule quantification in plasma and
serum we have then for urine we have
neonate quantification also we have the
same for adults and children and this
goes up to 150 metabolites currently and
is under constant expansion also we have
just introduced now this bio Bank QC
tool that I will also shortly introduce
if we actually collaborate with other
partners or groups then like in Christ's
world and they are using these SOPs then
of course if they develop certain essays
or tools then this can be actually added
to this platform so it's not only what
poka bio spin is offering it also will
be of course what our users are able to
contract
you
now these SOPs they act like an Internet
Protocol for example because that makes
it possible that everybody that is under
this SOPs can connect with each other
and of course we can also connect from
the Puka site and do some data analysis
for example
now I wanted to show you something about
that with usability which is one of the
strongholds of NMR and this is a result
which was done on a ring test with 11 IV
dr platforms in five organizations in
the United Kingdom in Germany but what
we are looking at here is actually just
the results of the QC samples which are
generated on those instruments and
eleven instruments as I mentioned and
you can see if we now look into
comparability as a poor disability of
the data you see this exactly on the
diagonal and we look to the R value then
this is basically 1 so we can also say
with this performance for example all
these 11 instruments they were able to
go into the right better than the
criteria which are explained or set by
the National cardiovascular education
program in the US where you can see for
example target imprecision target in
accuracy and also the total allow error
this is this brown bars and if you look
to the greenish one you can see the
results of these 11 instruments and you
see all of them are clearly in sight
this level so this is a clear proof for
the performance of NMR now as I
mentioned this is very important for bio
banks because what we can do there of
course we can offer an extensive quality
control for incoming samples that means
you can sort out a liquids with very low
quality for example or at least mark
them as having this issue of quality
when we do this QC process we generate
NMR data that can be stored in the bio
bank together with the metadata for
example and of course these data are
under complete standardization so if
more than one bio Bank does this then
all this data they are comparable so
that means we can actually then also and
you have see
that mentioned we can add the analysis
of for example the lipoprotein profiling
we can add the analysis on the urine
quantification all of this can go into
the bio bank together with the meta data
and of course then we can also do if we
have the meta data selected spectra from
based on meta data that are interesting
from this inventory and later if this is
standardized over multiple bio banks
which is something that of course will
support clinical trials which I will
explain in a moment
so the workflow when we look in this bio
Bank tool so the first thing of course
are the QC results so that means when
the sample is measured this QC analysis
and reporting is immediately done and
also then immediately available for
investigation and it was already
mentioned that we look for example in
the type of plasma whether it's serum we
we have many more parameters I am going
to mention now and of course some of
them are also NMR related because NMR
will also show us deviations now if we
look in for example plasma serum or
urine you see it in the upper table so
what is in the orange color this is for
them
matrix of urine and so we can do an
identity test again so is this really
urine we can do an integrity tests we
can do quantum II generation tests and
we can look into the preparation on the
NMR side and the measurement we can look
into medications we can look into
proteins backgrounds and we can test for
further parameters like for example in
the urine whether this was a fast
example or not so and of course
medication for example is quite
important because it is well known that
we have a lot of unreported parameters
which might not be in the metadata and
of course here there is a big help to
immediately identify whether there is
for example medication used and then
this would also explain outliers that
you might have in any statistically
investigation which is done afterwards
so then when we just look to some
examples you see here how we are
actually looking into
the protein background course protein
background of course in urine has
different reasons so like kidney damage
diabetes high blood pressure then
protein supplement in intake then fever
stress preeclampsia and of course that
can be compared also to metadata for
example so you can see on the right side
the spectra it shows a sample which has
in black which has a normal protein
background because there is in most
cases always a small background and you
can see the red color this is no example
where we have an extensive protein
background
next example here this is now looking
into contamination for example on the
right side you see a spectrum in the
upper part for plasma serum and then you
can see this yellow indicated peak which
sits on the lipoprotein signals for the
ch3 which would of course disturb
analysis that would be done we have
taken care of that in NMR but if you
have other tests then of course it is
important to know that there is
disinfection material like in this case
for example or we have for example
cleaning agents in urine like the
isopropanol on the left side the
spectrum you can see how we identify for
example whether this is an e d t a
plasma
and I mentioned already that you can add
a lot of information besides the
spectrum that can go into the bio bank
so there would be for example the 150
compounds which are quantified
automatically in urine and we have the
lipoproteins of glass analysis with up
to 115 parameters and we have the
quantification of small molecules which
is done exactly with the same experiment
in plasma in serum so you can add a lot
of information to the bio bank now let's
just think about the clinical trial so
the classic organization you have is to
generate these cohorts is you have an
organizing group and of course this
group is working together with other
groups that in addition also generate a
lot of samples but that means you you
really have a large sample cohort and
then of course a lot of samples have to
be stored a lot of samples has to be
analyzed so the question is how could
this be done in a different way so let's
assume we have bio banks which are
operating according to our NMR SOPs and
therefore of course create exchangeable
data then what we can of course now do
is for example if you look into control
data you could take them also from the
NMR spectra which are stored in the bio
bank for cohorts which are of course but
described by the metadata so that means
here could already be a substantial
reduction on additional samples that you
have to generate for the clinical trial
and like this of course you can
substantially reduce time and cost so
for at least for this NMR solution based
on reproduce ability this is what we can
do now I want to go a little bit back
into precision medicine you have already
seen this metabolic project ori and you
see that there are areas where this
project or we actually is quite stable
of course this
trajectory has been built from a large
number of participants but what you can
also do if you look to an individual
participant and you have longitudinal
study then you can for example discuss
about an index of change in the
metabolic profile of this person and of
course that is shown here on the right
side so if you have a normal development
then the metabolic profile will not
really change over several years and if
this starts to deviate then of course
you can change your lifestyle or you
have to take medication at the end now
the tool to do that actually and this
was done in a collaboration and project
with Sir min Florence professor looking
at we have looked into how can we
actually reduce this high variability in
urine because of course this depends
from what you take in in terms of food
that you take drugs nutraceuticals
Haussmann how your sport activities are
and this might be different every day so
we have developed the routine here how I
can subtract this variability and you
see that here with a person which
changes the hata hairstyle means it's
still the same person
it doesn't change or another person we
have exactly the same thing if we now
take spectra and we actually reduce the
daily variability then what you can see
if we compare for example in this graph
here the each of these between the black
stripes these are for the spectra of one
person and you see in the upper part
this shows the daily variation if you go
to the bottom you see how this is done
after we have subtracted this daily
variation now I just want to show you
how this can be actually applied and
this is now a follow-up study of the
initial study that was done because
there we can
we found out that we can identify people
by their urinary profile and if we now
look to the change of net and we have an
index of change which could tend to
earth disease so you have different
people here each of the colors is one
person you see here from 2005 to 2015
this study was executed that people have
given urine samples and you see some of
them are extremely stable and also have
severe deviations so if we look into
that now in more detail if we start for
example with the first one this is this
blue colored one in the beginning of the
graph then this was a female with two
pregnancies and in 2014 where this
really goes down it was Lester the lady
was breastfeeding and the profile
changes because no luck Tosun and
glycine up this is reported for
pregnancy and the lactating face as soon
as the lactating was ended you can see
in 2015 the original metabolic profile
actually was reestablished if you look
to the red one in the middle which shows
a large change this was a male which has
a longer antibiotic treatment and
developed the secondary lactose
intolerance in 2014 so that was then the
consequence to be strong pressure airy
from Diet gut microbiome changes
actually could also be seen if you look
to trigonal in deep uric acid and
hydroxy eyes of would you rate and some
asses also this person had was exposed
to a long term stress in 2015 actually
the dairy was resumed no antibiotics
anymore you can see the red curve goes
back to the normal profile and then we
have the the other died a blue one which
actually goes down you see towards the
end of this graph and actually here this
was a lady which also had two
pregnancies this was not lactating at
collections in 2014 but there was a
total spheroid removal because of
thyroid cancer and then thyroid hormone
treatment started and which this showed
up in a permanent distortion of the
metabolic profile so here it hasn't been
reestablished and you see the
metabolites which are actually changing
during this action so here you see a
very clear tool how you can actually
follow up the treatment
good then no go back to the slides and
I'm finished in a second this we have
seen I just want to show one last
example and this is the NMR based
screening using actually treatment
optimization engineers Kathy Nuria so
you see here in the different colors
these stars and circles these are
different medications which are taken
and you see the blue cohort the blue
ball represents healthy and the red one
represents the disease people and you
can see for example that the submarine
hydro diet or chloride actually can move
in such a metabolic profile into the
healthy version and of course you can do
that by optimizing the treatment we said
I'm done I hope I could show you that
NMR supports bio banking by
comprehensive quality control generating
additional data that can be used and
also supporting clinical trials I have
shown you that NMR can be used for
actually looking into precision medicine
and following individuals people's
actually metabolic profile so this is
good for optimizing the treatment with
that I would like to thank you for your
interest and so now I have Alexis again
with some more comments thank you
Thank You professor now found dr. Sproul
for your informative presentation if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the answer
question box locate jigna just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left ear screen will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
also questions submitted during the
argument period and those who don't have
time for today will be answered by email
the other contractors relationship
provided at the time of registration if
you don't have time to share with us for
the Q&A period please complete the poll
survey before leaving to let us know how
we did now let's get started
dr. Sproul over here good thank you
so start with the questions the first
one it says here that this is an
important presentation and that the
slides are needed to further follow up
so professor now has asked you to tell
us if that is possible
and of course also this webinar will be
only internet for one year but also just
a few remarks from personnel about that
one please yes of course the
presentation is open mind there will be
no problem tour to send it to the people
who are interested in
thank you now there was another question
to your presentation actually various
asked if slide 18 is NMR based in your
presentation
look the
so the answer is no it's what the Vice
g5 and this was a classical clinical
chemistry essay
this was an example to show that in
general technical caps chemistry when we
change or platform that we observe many
cases relevant shifts between platform a
and platform beam and this is one of the
real advantages of the NMR spectroscopy
that in this view we do not have any
changes in accuracy
okay
hello
dr. Sproul
oh it appears that dr. sprawl
has lost his connection we do apologize
there are quite a few questions that are
still in our queue and I see more coming
in those questions and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of the registration additionally a
short exit poll will pop up on your
screen your feedback is important to us
thank you so much for participating we
would like to thank professor Maasai's
NOC for his time today and his important
research we would also like to thank
laberd's mr. Manfred's Brawl and our
sponsor berger for underwriting today's
educational webcasts this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through May of 2019
labret slow alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live but until next time goodbye